body camera footage shows the tense
moments before a deadly shooting in
Texas after officers complete hours of
Crisis negotiation in a possible hostage
situation
going back towards us it happened in
Austin Texas on September 23rd 9-1-1
dispatch received a call at about 9 20
that morning from a woman reporting a
domestic disturbance with the father of
her children my baby daddy's here on
property and he's trespassed in and I'm
trying to get my kids from him but I
told him yeah he's over here at my
apartment the woman told officers the
man later identified as Antonio Gonzalez
was getting physical has he gotten
physical with you at all or just arguing
with yourself
and had a weapon do you see any weapons
on him or know that he has any
yes he does do you see one on him or you
just know he has one no he has a gun on
him
do you see it
yes so where's the gun at right now
believing it to be a possible hostage
situation officers arrived on the scene
about 15 minutes after that 9-1-1 call
came in at the time Gonzalez did not
have any children but was armed with a
weapon we're trying to get you water bro
stop moving we're trying to get you
water officers on the scene attempted to
de-escalate the situation asking
Gonzalez to lay on the ground instead he
continued to walk around the area armed
with the handgun a crisis intervention
officer and SWAT vehicle were called
after Gonzalez threatened to kill
himself several times
no problem
it's going back towards us for nearly
two hours officers work to de-escalate
the situation speaking to Gonzalez on
the phone again he threatened to shoot
himself if officers did not shoot him
officers attempted to tase Gonzalez but
were unsuccessful after he reached for
the gun in his waistband officials
opened fire
after the shooting Gonzalez was
pronounced dead at the scene four
officers involved have been placed on
administrative leave as multiple
investigations into the incident are
conducted for the latest developments in
this story and all things True Crime
stay with long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie